-Former Vice President
Mike Pence
was heckled and called a traitor
at a conservative conference
last week
by a group
of antifa socialists.
Wait, sorry, I read that wrong.
By his own party.
Meanwhile, the GOP's sham
election audit in Arizona
has taken yet
another bizarre turn,
with copies of voting data
being driven
to a mysterious location
in Montana.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
We're five months
into Joe Biden's presidency
and, yet, Republicans
are still obsessed
with trying to overturn the
results of the 2020 election
and rewrite the history
of what happened
during the January 6th
insurrection at the Capitol.
This weekend, for example,
Wisconsin Senator Ron Johnson
and Fox host Maria Bartiromo
once again repeated the lie
that none of the
insurrectionists were armed.
-Armed insurrection
is what Nancy Pelosi
keeps calling January 6th,
Senator.
How many guns were actually
taken up on that day,
since she says it was armed?
-By the way, they always talk
about thousands
of armed insurrectionists.
I asked the FBI witness.
Not one.
Not one gun was recovered,
either in the Capitol
or on the Capitol grounds,
according to that FBI witness,
so that's just one
of the latest big lies.
-And, as we all know, guns are
the only types of weapons.
That's why you're allowed to get
on an airplane with nunchucks
and giant medieval battle-axes.
And, yet, every time I go
through security
with my nunchucks and battle-ax,
security's always like,
"Um, excuse me, sir.
You can't take that with you."
And then I have to remind them
that, under Article 47
of the U.S. Constitution,
part 9, subsection 23(B),
nunchucks and battle-axes are
allowed on airplanes.
And they say, "No,
I meant the shampoo.
That's clearly
a four-ounce bottle."
And then, to ease the tension,
I say something like,
"Hey, you can't have
this battle-ax,
but you can have
this one over there,"
[ Laughing ]
and then, I gesture to my wife
and we all have a good laugh.
[ Laughter ]
Well, not all of us.
Someone takes it very personally
and then, it's a thing
the whole vacation.
[ Laughter ]
Also,
more importantly,
none of that is true.
Last week, prosecutors charged
a fourth Capital riot defendant
with a firearms violation.
And, aside from guns,
according to CNN...
If a dude broke your window
and busted into your house
with a hockey stick at 3:00 am
and said, "Don't worry.
I'm not armed,"
you wouldn't say like,
"Oh, alright, well,
you want to crack a beer
and watch the highlights
from the Islanders game?
Did you see that save
by Ryan Pulock?!
Hey, where are you going
with my vase?"
[ Laughter ]
And then, at the end
of the interview, Bartiromo,
one of the most unhinged
conspiracy theorists on Fox,
applauded herself
for telling the truth.
-We have been telling
every story.
We've been on the right side
of it for seven years going.
I've been trashed every day
along the way.
Keep trashing me!
I'll keep telling the truth!
-That sounds like a catchphrase
from the opening credits of...
[ Laughter ]
[ As Bartiromo ]
Keep trashing me!
I'll keep telling the truth!
Andy!
Andy, stop hitting your brother
with the pool skimmer!
Andy!
Put that down right now!
I'm going to call your father!
What's that?
Oh, you're unarmed
because it's just
a pool skimmer?
Now, he's getting cute with me.
Andy Michael Piazza DeAngelo,
put it down right now,
or I will end you!
[ Laughter ]
These people have been
desperately cycling
through one deranged
conspiracy theory after another,
in an attempt to lie about what
really happened on January 6th.
Some tried to claim it was
largely a peaceful protest,
no worse than
a "normal tourist visit,"
while others suggested
that it was actually the FBI
and the deep state that secretly
orchestrated the whole thing,
as a false flag operation.
And then, there were those
who blamed
so-called fake Trump supporters
or antifa,
despite the pro-Trump rioters
themselves going online
and contradicting that lie.
-The people who stormed
the Capitol
had to convince their own
brethren on social media
they weren't antifa,
like Brian Nichols, a Marine
veteran charged in the attack,
who wrote on Facebook,
"Hey..."
-You know it's bad when
even the insurrectionists
are fact-checking Republicans.
Soon, anti-vaxxers are going
to start tweeting stuff like...
They can't even get the people
they're lying about
to go along with the lie.
It would be like if OJ
got up in court and said,
"Those gloves fit just fine.
I was making my hands big
on purpose,"
and then, Judge Ito looks
at the camera and says, "Juice!"
I feel like that's what he'd do.
[ Laughter ]
I was younger then.
In reality, of course,
the insurrection was
an attempt to stop the lawful
counting of electoral votes
and overturn the results
to keep Trump in power.
In fact, a large faction
of GOP officials and voters
are still very much committed
to the big lie
that fueled the riot,
in the first place.
A new poll out today finds
that...
...and last week, former
Vice President Mike Pence
was heckled and called a traitor
at the conservative
Faith & Freedom Coalition
because he didn't singlehandedly
overturn the results
of the election,
which he didn't have
the power to do, anyway.
-Pence is the one seen
on surveillance video
being rushed to safety by the
Secret Service on January 6th.
Remember, rioters could be heard
chanting, "Hang Mike Pence."
Trump had accused him
of being disloyal
for following the Constitution
and refusing to overturn
the election results.
Well, today, Pence spoke
to religious conservatives
at the Faith & Freedom
Coalition Conference
and, as he tried to speak,
boos and cries of "traitor"
rained down from the crowd.
-It is great to be back
with so many patriots.
And I want to thank
my friend Ralph Reed
for those overly generous words.
I'm deeply humbled by them.
And Ralph Reed knows me
well enough to know
the introduction I prefer
is a little bit shorter.
I'm a Christian, a conservative,
and a Republican,
in that order.
-Man, that's like getting booed
throwing out a first pitch
at a baseball game
in your home state,
which also happened
to Mike Pence.
-[ Booing and whistling ]
[ Applause ]
-[Bleep] you!
-You suck!
[ Laughter ]
-Booing is one thing,
but they're calling Pence
a traitor
and he tries to just keep
giving his speech
and act like it's not happening.
Pence could really use
a Smithers right about now.
[ As Smithers ]
They're not saying traitor.
They're saying,
"Tra-yay!-tor."
[ Laughter ]
Also, it's a gathering
of religious conservatives,
called the
Faith & Freedom Coalition.
Pence should be able to walk
into that place
like Norm walking into Cheers.
"Mike!
What's shaking, Mr. Pence?"
[ As Pence ] The knees
of the faithless, Woody.
[ Laughter ]
If Pence should be popular
anywhere, it's there,
and, yet, he's still
getting booed.
That's like the Kardashians
getting booed on E!
-Did you get Kendall a present?
-I did.
-What'd you get?
-Something for her lake house.
-[ Booing ]
-Oh, nice.
-You suck!
-And, yeah, I'm aware
the Kardashians have been
moved from E! to Hulu.
Just because most
of my references are
from the '70s and '80s
doesn't mean I don't know
anything about the Kardashians.
I know pop culture better
than Radar O'Reilly knows
the sound of a helicopter.
[ Laughter ]
As Mike Pence
has now discovered,
the core organizing principle
of the GOP right now is
its fundamental hostility
to democracy
and the movement's
central belief is
the big lie that the
2020 election was stolen.
More than half a Republicans
said, in a recent poll,
that they still believe election
reviews will change the outcome,
like the sham audit in Arizona,
where Republicans have been
hunting for, among other things,
bamboo fibers,
to prove that ballots
were smuggled in from China;
and secret watermarks,
left by Trump,
that separate the real ballots
from the fake ones.
They think Trump watermarked
ballots when, in reality,
the only thing he's ever
watermarked is a desk.
I guarantee Trump has never used
a coaster in his life,
even though
"Coaster" was probably
his nickname in high school.
"Hey Coaster, is it true you had
someone else take your SATs?"
[ As Trump ]
All that matters is
I got into "Peen."
"Do you mean Penn?"
[ As Trump ]
Cicada, "sih-kah-duh."
[ Laughter ]
In fact,
the Arizona audit has gotten
so far off the rails
that copies of voting data
have been taken
to a mysterious location
somewhere in rural Montana,
all in the name
of election integrity.
CNN even tried
to find the location
and sent a reporter
to the woods to look for it.
-On this piece of property
in a remote part of Montana,
people may,
at this very minute,
be analyzing voting data
from the state of Arizona,
as part of the so-called
Arizona audit,
run by the Cyber Ninjas,
a company whose CEO
had previously espoused
Trump-style election
conspiracy theories.
What does Montana have to do
with all this?
Ken Bennett is a spokesman
for the audit.
-Everything that Cyber Ninjas
is doing,
they're either doing
with their own expertise
or the expertise of the people
that are hired.
[ Laughter ]
-Cool. Well, thanks
to Republican
conspiracy theories,
we have CNN reporters running
around in the woods
like they're auditioning
for "Finding Bigfoot."
Also, you trust a company
that calls itself Cyber Ninjas
to hire people with expertise?
It sounds like a game
for Super Nintendo
you'd find at the bottom
of the bargain bin
at GameStop in 1994,
or a [bleep] Steven Seagal
ripoff of "Robocop."
"You're too late, copper.
We already got the jewels
from the safe."
[ As Seagal ]
I'm not a cop.
I'm a cyber ninja.
Digital nunchucks, activate.
Wh-What do you mean,
I can't get on the plane?
Am I supposed to walk
to my dojo?
[ Laughter ]
But the story
keeps getting weirder.
Even the spokesman
for the Arizona audit
apparently has no idea
where the Cyber Ninjas
have taken the voting data.
-And the contractor it hired
is called Cipher, LLC.
Bennett says
Cipher was permitted
to take copies of Arizona
voting system data on a truck
and have it driven to Montana,
where it's being
"forensically evaluated,"
in what he described
as a "secure,
powerful laboratory."
But nobody is publicly saying
what that actually means
and Bennett tells us he doesn't
know where the so-called lab is.
It is apparently a secret.
-Wait, so we're supposed
to believe
there's a secret, powerful
laboratory in rural Montana
where experts are doing
forensic analysis on ballots?
Also, why do I keep saying
"rural Montana"?
"Montana" is fine.
There's no urban Montana.
"You'll never make it on the
mean streets of Billings, kid."
[ Laughter ]
And, look, I love Montana,
but I'm having trouble believing
there's some secret,
powerful laboratory
where they're doing
forensic analysis
hidden in the middle of nowhere,
unless it was built
by Tony Stark.
[ Gasp ]
And, if that were true,
then the only person
who'd be able to find it
would be Loki.
[ Gasp ]
But, wait! It's just like Loki
to use a sham audit
as an excuse to alter
the sacred timeline.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my God!
Is this --
Is this a nexus event?
Have the Timekeepers
lost control of the variant?
Oh, God!
Does this mean there won't be
a "Wedding Crashers" sequel?
[ Laughter ]
[ As Wilson ] Jeez, man, relax!
It's just a TV show.
You're losing the plot, man.
[ Laughter ]
The Biden presidency can feel
deceptively calm,
compared to the Trump era,
but there's a brewing crisis
on the horizon.
One of our two
major political parties
is controlled
by an authoritarian faction
that is radicalized
against democracy.
They're still trying
to overturn the results
of the last election,
all while making it easier
to overturn the next election.
Republicans believe
they're the only ones
who can legitimately
win elections,
no matter how many times
voters tell them...
-You suck!
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.